let's talk about Flatliners Flatliners
this is a sequel to a movie where the
medical students young medical students
are experimenting with ways to see if
there's an afterlife it's sort of using
these different medical techniques this
is a very intense subject obviously I
don't know if you have your own beliefs
about the afterlife through your freedom
I grew up watching Star Wars you know so
I believe more in the force you believe
in the force right or some some kind of
energy my mom died when I was 2 and I've
made wrong choices over and over the
most stupid ones you know and I'm still
here sitting in Conan probably yeah yeah
you saying this is one of your stupid
choice it sounded like yeah that what
I'm saying is this is some energy I
think some some love of my mom taking
care of me be quiet doesn't matter how
the stupid choices I make I'm still here
doing what I love and and I do believe
in that I do believe we go and we are
part of this in some kind of different
way and and and those who were happy in
their lives they they become energy that
helps others to reach that you know it's
a beautiful Eve in the force and I don't
believe we come back as someone else or
I don't know but you know what the most
important thing it worried me when I was
a kid when I was a teenager now it
doesn't worry me at all in fact I want
to find out this as far as possible from
today you know right it's a lot for me
to do in this world and I don't want to
be thinking about what happens when I'm
not around
but these medical students do you know
and and it's it's it's a there was a
film previous to this one that I grew up
watching so it means a lot to be part of
this project because I I did spend many
nights thinking of Julia Roberts on that
film
yeah I mean haven't no oh yeah you know
I don't know but man you know I've never
seen the original so yeah are you having
some new put it on all right it'll put
me to sleep
I wasn't I will I was so gorgeous
okay I need that film she looked amazing
and it was my introduction to Julia
Roberts well you're here promoting the
film from the
[Applause]
you